go hang out with monks for a month do
something away from everybody
and decide what you want to do because
the world loved the will who was will
nobody likes a guy that's acting like
trying to be somebody else that the
publicist or the media or the market or
hollywood wants you to be no one's
turned on by that nobody take a page out
of this tate guy that's going viral why
do you think he is going viral because
he doesn't give a [ __ ] what you think
his background i've never done business
with this guy i don't know what is back
everybody's asking me about what about
this and what about that and what about
this i think most of people in the world
are pissed because how viral he's going
and how much you know what he called it
how much attention he's getting how come
i'm not getting it the algorithms are
favoring kim he's got a better strategy
than you ask yourself well why is he
doing so well
why is he doing something he's an
unapologetic badass that says what's on
his mind that's what will smith needs
but what do the algorithms and the world
say
what do the algorithms and the world say
keep it coming the the algorithms and
the world says that's exactly what we
like we